اهلا بكم الى اين تتجه الامور في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه كوريا الشماليه حذرت من
انها على استعداد لاجراء تجربه نوويه
سادسه في في اي وقت وطالبت الولايات
المتحده بالتخلي عما وصفتها بسياساتها
العدائيه من جانبها لم تكتفي الاخيره
باجراء مناورات بحريه وبريه مشتركه مع
كوريا الجنوبيه فقد بدات تشغيل نظام ثاد
المضاد للصواريخ على الاراضي الكوريه
الجنوبيه لاعتراض اي صاروخ كوري شمالي
الصين دخلت على خط الازمه وطلبت بتعليق
العمل بتلك المنظومه محذره من عواقب
التصعيد تقرير مريم
ابيش
حرب الصواريخ وانظمه الصواريخ المضاده في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه هل تتوقف عند
التصريحات واستعراض القوى ام سيبلغ مداها
اكثر مما ينبغي نظام الدرع الصاروخي ثاد
المثير للجدل يثير مره اخرى غضب بيجين
وبيونج يون وحتى سكان منطقه سيونجو في
كوريا الجنوبيه بعد يوم فقط من اعلان
واشنطن ان ثاد اصبح فعالا وقادرا على
اعتراض صواريخ كوريا الشماليه دعت
الخارجيه الين الى التعليق الفوري
له نحن نعارض نشر نظام الثاد في كوريا
الجنوبيه وندعو الاطراف الى وقفه فورا
وسنتخذ بحزم الاجراءات اللازمه للدفاع عن
مصالحنا تخشى بيجين ان يضعف الدرع
الصاروخي انظمتها الصاروخيه البالستيه
لكنها تفضل تبرير موقفها بالقول انه يمثل
تهديدا للاستقرار الاقليمي في حين ترى
واشنطن وسول انه ضرور لردع كوريا الشماليه
ونظامها الذي لا يتوقف عن تحدي الجميع
بالقيام بتجارب صاروخيه نوويه طرحت فكره
نشره عام
2016 ولم تصل القطع والمنصات الى كوريا
الجنوبيه سوى الاسبوع الماضي اي بعد يوم
واحد فقط من اطلاق كوريا الشماليه اربعه
صواريخ باليستيه ولكن ما هو نظام دفاع
المناطق المرتفعه او ثاد يستطيع اسقاط
الصواريخ البالستيه القصيره والمتوسطه
خلال المرحله النهائيه من رحلتها يستخدم
تكنولوجيا ادرب لتقتل والتي تدمر فيها
رؤوس الصواريخ القادمه يبلغ نطاق النظام
200 ر وقد يصل ارتفاعه الى 150 كتر نشرت
واشنطن سابقا هذا النظام في جوام وهاواي
تحسبا لاي اعتداء كوري شمالي لا يرحب كثير
من سكان كوريا الجنوبيه بهذا النظام لانهم
يعتقدون انه قد يكون هدف دفن وهو ما قد
يعرض سكان منطقه سيونجو للخطر المهم ان
المنظومه نفسها تشغل حاليا الاله
الدبلوماسيه لكل دول المنطقه التي تخشى
فعلا من تصعيد التوتر خاصه مع رئيسين مثل
كيم جونغ اون ودونالد ترامب بيونج يونغ
تحذر انها على استعداد للقيام بتجربه
نوويه سادسه في اي وقت والرئيس ترامب صرح
انه من دواعي الشرف ان يلتقي كيم جونغ اون
لو توفرت لهذا اللقاء الشروط المناسبه من
بين تلك الشروط وفق المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض وان ينحسر فورا السلوك الاستفزازي
لكوريا الشماليه بلد يرى في التحركات
العسكريه الامريكيه على حدوده ايضا
استفزازا ماذا لو وصل الاستفزاز المتبادل
اقصاه والاخطر ان يترجم بلغه الصواريخ
والصواريخ المضاده شبه الجزيره الكوريه في
عهد ترامب وكيم الابن مفتوحه على كل
الاحتمالات حتى الاكثر تهورا منها كما
يبدو حتى الان على
الاقل ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور جيمز
روبنز كبير الباحثين في المجلس الامريكي
لسياسه الخارجيه والمسؤول السابق في وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه لشؤون الامن القومي
دكتور اهلا بك اولا الى ما تؤشر مقاربه
اداره الرئيس ترامب لازمه شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
اداره ترامب قلقه جدا بشان برنامج كوريا
شماليه النوويه وخاصه قدرات كوريا
الشماليه على ان تحمل اسلحه النوويه على
صاروخ وان تقوم بتوجيهها ضد الولايات
المتحده اذا فادار الان تضع اطارا هيكليا
لكي تحاول ان تكون هناك شبه جزيره كوريه
منزوعه من السلاح النووي في هذا الاطار
سيد جيمز ما هي فعاليه نظام ثاد في تحييد
صواريخ كوريا
الشماليه ان نظام الدرع الصاروخيه الثاد
هوز من
مجموعه من انظمه المضاده للصواريخ
بغيه حمايه كوريا الجنوبيه وهذه المنظومه
هي دفاعيه ضد الصواريخ متوسطه المدى
وطويله المدى وهي التي قد يستخدمها نظام
كوريا الشماليه ضد كوريا الجنوبيه اما
بطريقه متعمده او في حاله اطلاق يحدث عن
طريق الخطا باتجاه كوريا الجنوبيه كوريا
الشماليه سيد جيمز تقول ان التواجد
الامريكي قرب مياهه الاقليميه وايضا هذه
المناورات
المستمره مع كوريا الجنوبيه تشكل استفزازا
لها وخطرا على امنها القومي هل يمكن
لاداره ترامب بتقديرك ان تاخذ بهواجس
كوريا الشماليه بالهواجس الصينيه وايضا
الهواجس
الروسيه
هذه المناورات التي تجري لاعوام على ارض
شبه الجزيره الكوريه التغييرات التي تجري
مؤخرا كانت
بتاكيد كوريا الشماليه على تصليح منظومتها
الصاروخيه
وتطويل مدى وصول صواريخها ليس فقط لتصل
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان ولكن الولايات
المتحده واستراليا ودول اخرى في المح حيط
الهادئ اذا فهو استفزاز من كوريا الشماليه
هو الذي يؤجج الوضع الحالي حيث انها تقوم
بزياده قدراتها الصاروخيه وذلك الولايات
المتحده تقوم بوضع هذه المنظومه لكي يكون
هناك ردع لكوريا الشماليه وهذه النشاطات
التي تقوم بها سيد جيمز الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب صرح وانا اقرا انقل عنه هنا
بانه سيكون من دواعي الشرف لديه ان يلتقي
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي اذا توافرت الظروف
او الشروط الملائمه ينتهي الاقتباس ما هي
الشروط برايكم بالنسبه لامريكا لكي يعني
يلتقي الرجلان او ان تتخلى ربما اداره
ترامب عن هذا التصعيد تجاه كوريا
الشماليه اعتقد ان كوريا الشماليه اذا ما
اظهرت النيه الحسنه بالتزامها بقرار مجلس
الامن الدولي للتخلص من برنامجها الصاروخي
ولكي تتخلى من اسلحتها النوويه واعتقد ان
كوريا الشماليه لن تفعل هذا ولكن مبادره
بالنيه الحسنه من قبل كوريا الشماليه سوف
تقطع شوطا طويلا مما يجعل الرئيس
ترامب قادر وسوف يقوم بلقاء كيم جونج اون
في ظل هذه الظروف طيب سيد جيمز ينضم الينا
الان عبر سكايب من شانغهاي الدكتور وانج
بينغ الباحث معه جهار ومعهد الصين بجامعه
فودان لنفهم وجهه نظر الصين فيما يتعلق
بهذه المنظومه الدفاعيه كما تقول الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه سييد بين ما اسباب قلق
الصين من نشر منظومه ثاد الصاروخيه
الدفاعيه في كوريا
الجنوبيه هناك اسباب وجيهه تجعل الصين
قلقه بشان نشر الدع الوخيه الثات في كوريا
الجنوبيه من قبل الولايات المتحده الهدف
الاساسي هو ليس الصين ونحن نفهم هذا ولكن
من ناحيه تقنيه فدرع
الصاروخيه
ثاد تهدف الى حمايه كوريا الجنوبيه من اي
تهديد قد ي من كوريا الشماليه طيب هل لدى
الصين سيد بنج بتصورك هل لدى الصين
بتصورك معلومات او او هل هل فهمت لماذا
تسعى دائما كوريا الشماليه لتطوير صواريخ
عابره للقارات وايضا لاجراء
مناورات نوويه تشكل تهديدا لدول
الجوار
اوكي من وجهه نظر
الصين
هذه
العمليات التي تتم
هناك هي بالطبع مقلقه
للصين
اذا ما كان هناك هجوم من كوريا الشماليه
على كوريا الجنوبيه فهذا الاحتمال غير
وارد
وهذا ينضوي في اطار نظريه المؤامره التي
تستخدم لتبرير نشر هذه الدرع الصاروخيه
ثاد في كوريا الجنوبيه
لذلك فليس هناك حجه حقيقيه لنشر هذه
المنظومه الصاروخيه
ثاد
ايضا هذا
ياتي في
محاوله منافسته الصين من قبل الولايات
المتحده
ولتحقيق
عفوا سيد بينغ انا سالتك هل لدى
الصين فكره عن لماذا تسعى دائما كوريا
الشماليه بتطوير صواريخ عابره للقارات
وايضا باجراء مناورات او بتجارب صاروخيه
نوويه تعتبرها دول الجوار بانها تخل
بالامن القومي لهذه الدول هل لدى الصين
تصور لماذا تسعى كوريا الشماليه الى هذا
الامر نسمع معكم سيد بينك
تفضل
ي طيب سنعود لك سيد
جيمز في حال تطورت الامور
ونفذ وعوده زعيم كوريا الشم باجراء تجارب
نوويه جديده ما السيناريو المتوقع برايكم
خصوصا فيما يتعلق برد الفعل
الامريكي لا اعتقد ان هذا الوضع سيكون
مفضلا لكوريا الشماليه وعليهم ان لا
يقوموا باي اختبارات صاروخيه جديده ذلك
لان الولايات المتحده عندها ستحظى بفرصه
للرد على ذلك حتى الصين حذ رت كوريا
الشماليه من القيام بمزيد من التجارب
الصاروخيه وهذا من شانه ان يزيد الوضع
السوء ولا سبب لذلك ولا داعي لذلك انما هو
كيم جون اون يحاول ان يزيد من الازمه من
خلال استعراض العضلات واستعراض القوه في
كوريا الشماليه وينبغي عليه ان لا يقوم
بذلك ما حدود هذا الرد الامريكي باختصار
سيد جيمز خصوصا في ظل رفض صيني ورفض روسي
لاي رد فعل امريكي في المنطقه باختصار لو
سمحت اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده لن تقوم
بهجوم احادي على كوريا الشماليه ورغم هذا
اعتقد ان التعاون الصوني في حل هذه الازمه
مهم وملح الحكومه
الصينيه قامت توجيه تحذيرات غير مسبوقه
لكوريا الشماليه بان لا تسير في هذا
المسار وان تعرض العلاقات الكوريه
الشماليه والصينيه للخطر ريس ترامب قال ان
الصين سوف تحظى بعلاقات تجاريه مفضله مع
الولايات المتحده اذا ما ساعدت في التعاون
لحل هذه الازمه اذا فالطريق والسبيل لحل
هذه الازمه يمر عبر بيجين ولا ارى
الولايات المتحده ستقوم بشن هجوم لوحدها
على كوريا الشماليه شكرا لكما جيمز روبنز
كبير الباحثين في المجلس الامريكي للسياسه
الخارجيه والمسؤول السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لشؤون الامن القومي واشكر من
شانغهاي الدكتور وانج بينغ الباحث في معهد
جهار ومعهد الصين بجامعه فودان كنا نود
التحدث معك اكثر ولكن هناك مشكله في
التواصل شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا
نصل الى نهايه الحصاد الى اللقاء بامان
الله
[موسيقى]
ورعايته
ه